the FBI is saying a local man scaled the
side of the Capitol building in
Washington D.C thanks for joining us
tonight at six I'm Sasha Loftus and I'm
Brian loftus-8 news now investigator
David charts tracking this story joining
us now live in our Newsroom with more
David well Brian and Sasha this arrest
marking the third person in our Valley
the fourth here in Nevada charged for
their roles on January 6th the FBI is
saying 39 year old Brandon Dillard is
the person wearing the black clothing in
these photos the images filed in the
criminal complaint against him
investigators say Dillard scaled the
side of the Capitol building and then
entered it through a broken window now
this video is part of a different
January 6 defendant's criminal case it
appears to show a person matching the
description prosecutors say is Dillard
you see that person there climbing down
the side of the building as that massive
group of people pushes its way against a
line of police blocking a door there
prosecutors say they match photos of
Dillard to his Nevada driver's license
if federal judge releasing him from
custody as he now awaits a hearing in
Washington D.C I did reach out to his
attorney today and I did not hear back
Brian
all right David thank you two other men
arrested here in Las Vegas have since
pleaded guilty for their involvement in
January 6. one is serving a 63 months
prison sentence the other awaiting
sentences the FBI has charged 1 000
people for their roles in the
insurrection